♪ ♪
>> Bret: CONGRESS WILL HAVE A
LOT TO DEAL WITH WHEN LAWMAKERS
RETURN FROM THEIR SUMMER RECESS.
GUN CONTROL AT THE TOP OF THE
DEMOCRAT'S AGENDA.
WAS ALSO OBVIOUSLY IMMIGRATION
REFORM AND EVERYONE IS KEEPING
AN EYE ON HONG KONG, NORTH KOREA
AND IRAN.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A LOT TO TALK
ABOUT WITH HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY OF CALIFORNIA.
HE IS ON A TRIP AND ISRAEL.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: LET'S START ON YOUR
TRIP, WHAT YOU'RE TAKING FROM IT
AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING THERE.
>> 31 OF THE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
OVER AND WE ARE WALKING THROUGH
ISRAEL, OUR GREATEST ALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, THE ONLY COUNTRY IN
THE MIDDLE EAST THAT IS A
DEMOCRACY.
MET WITH THE PRIME MINISTER,
PRIME MINISTER OF THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY.
WE ARE UP AT THE BORDER OF
LEBANON LOOKING HAS BLOUSE
TUNNELS THAT THEY HAVE RECENTLY
DISCOVERED COMING ACROSS OVER
INTO ISRAEL.
IT GIVES YOU A VERY CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CHALLENGES
FOR A PEACE PROCESS HERE BUT
IT'S A WAY THAT A LOT OF THE NEW
FRESHMAN CAN SEE IT ON THE
GROUND AND WE ACTUALLY MADE A
BIPARTISAN.
STENY HOYER AND I MAKE SURE THE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS CAME
TOGETHER FOR A NUMBER OF DAYS
HERE IN ISRAEL TO LOOK AT THE
CHALLENGES TOGETHER AND
UNDERSTAND HOW DO WE MAINTAIN
THIS BOND AND EVEN GROW IT.
>> Bret: USE IT THIS IS
BIPARTISAN BUT ON THIS TRIP
YOU'VE ALSO EXPRESSED HER
CONCERNS ABOUT "THE SQUAD," THE
FRESHMAN DEMOCRATS WHO YOU SAY
THEY ARE TAKING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AWAY FROM
ISRAEL.
EXPLAIN THAT.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT IT, THEY DID
NOT COME ON THE TRIP WITH THEIR
COLLEAGUES.
SECONDLY, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ANTI-SEMITISM THAT HAS BEEN
GROWING AROUND THE WORLD, WE
HAVEN'T SEEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
SINCE THE 1930s, AND THE
ACTIONS THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN IN
CONGRESS ITSELF, WHEREAS THE
SENATE PASSED AS ONE, IT'S THE
STOPPING OF THE BOYCOTT AND
SANCTIONS AGAINST ISRAEL.
THAT BILL PASSED THE SENATE
OVERWHELMINGLY.
CHUCK SCHUMER NOT ONLY VOTED IT
STOMACH FOR IT, HE COSPONSORED
IT.
BUT WHEN IT CAME TO THE HOUSE
THEY COULDN'T PASS THE BILL.
THEY MOVED A RESOLUTION AND MUCH
OF THAT WAS TO DO ABOUT THIS NEW
MOVEMENT OF THIS NEW SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC.
LOOK AT BERNIE SANDERS, LOOK AT
KAMALA HARRIS, WOULDN'T EVEN GO
TO THE AIPAC MEETING THIS YEAR
INSIDE WASHINGTON.
UNHEARD OF IN THE PROCESS THAT'S
BEEN GOING FORWARD.
A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS THAT STILL
STAND WITH ISRAEL, BUT THIS NEW
SOCIALIST DEMOCRAT GROUP HAS A
MUCH DIFFERENT BELIEF.
>> Bret: AXIOS IS REPORTING
THAT THE PRESIDENT TOLD AMERICAN
ADVISORS, INCLUDING SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS, THAT
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR AND TLAIB
SHOULD BE BARRED FROM GOING TO
ISRAEL.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
COMMENTING, ISRAEL IS NOT BORING
BUT ANY THOUGHT ON THAT?
YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT HAD
THOSE BELIEFS?
>> I NEVER HAD THE PRESIDENT SAY
THAT TO ME.
BUT THE ONE THING THAT SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED, THEY SHOULD HAVE
COME WITH THEIR COLLEAGUES.
THEY SHOULD'VE COME TOGETHER
WHERE THEY COULD HAVE A MEETING
WITH ISRAEL, WITH THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY, WITH
THOSE WHO WERE RUNNING AT THE
SAME TIME.
YOU WOULD GET EVERY VIEW THAT
YOU WANTED TO SEE.
AS LONG AS YOU COME WITH AN OPEN
MIND, OPEN EYES AND OPEN EARS, I
THINK YOU HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO COME HERE TO HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING.
>> Bret: 'S TALK ABOUT THE
OTHER ISSUES OF THE DAY THAT ARE
PRESSING.
THE HOUSE SPEAKER CALLING FOR
ACTION ON GUN CONTROL
LEGISLATION.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE MUST PASS GUN PREVENTION
LEGISLATION.
EVERY DAY WE LOSE LIVES.
AND NOW PUBLIC SENTIMENT MUST
WEIGH IN TO SAVE LIVES, TO PASS
OUR BILL TO LOOK AT
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES THAT
COULD BE ELIMINATED AS WELL.
>> Bret: THAT BILL DID PASS
THE HOUSE, EIGHT REPUBLICANS
VOTED FOR IT.
YOU VOTED NO ON THIS BACKGROUND
CHECK BILL THAT INCLUDED OTHER
THINGS.
IT'S NOW SITTING IN THE SENATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE SENATE
SHOULD DO?
>> I THINK THE SENATE SHOULD
ACTUALLY PASSABLE IT ACTUALLY
WORKS.
YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS
THIS LAST CONGRESS DONE?
WHEN WE SAW A SHOOTING LIKE IN
PARKLAND WHERE THAT
INDIVIDUAL -- WHENEVER WANT TO
SAY HIS NAME, THE FBI WAS WARNED
NOT ONCE, BUT TWICE MONTHS AHEAD
OF TIME AND NO ACTION WAS TAKEN.
WE SAW THAT SHOOTING IN TEXAS AT
A CHURCH.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE WAS THE
NATIONAL CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECK FAILED.
IT WAS OUR OWN MILITARY THAT NO
LONGER GAVE ME INFORMATION SO WE
CHANGE THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BUMP STOP
THAT CAME THROUGH DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TOOK THAT BACK.
WE WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING THAT WORKS.
WE ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
ANYBODY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
OUR DUE PROCESS BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO PROTECT THE AMERICANS WHO
SHOULD HAVE THESE WEAPONS AS
WELL.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID HE WANTED TO SEE MEANINGFUL
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON TUESDAY.
HE SAID MITCH McCONNELL WANTS
SOMETHING TO HAPPEN.
YOU VOTED AGAINST THAT BILL IN
THE HOUSE.
DO YOU THINK SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN?
>> BECAUSE THAT BILL DOES NOT
GIVE YOU MEANINGFUL BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
YOU COULD WRITE A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY DOES THAT, AND I AM
MORE THAN WILLING TO SIT DOWN
WITH ANYONE AT WORK ON IT.
I'VE REACHED OUT TO MITCH AS
WELL, McCONNELL, TO FIND A WAY
THAT WE CAN WORK ON THAT.
SPOKEN TO THE PRESIDENT NUMEROUS
TIMES, WE WANT A PROCESS THAT
WORKS.
WE ALSO WANT TO PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE BILLS -- WE HAVE LAWS TODAY
THAT AREN'T ENFORCED.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO TRY TO
BUY A WEAPON WHO DO NOT LEGALLY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO IT, LESS
THAN 8% OF THOSE ARE EVEN
PROSECUTED TODAY.
>> Bret: WANT TO GO THROUGH A
COUPLE OF ISSUES VERY QUICKLY.
ONE IS YOUR CONCERN ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN HONG KONG AND WHAT
POTENTIAL OF THE U.S. COULD OR
COULD NOT DO ABOUT IT.
>> FIRST OF ALL AMERICA SHOULD
STAND WITH THOSE WHO BELIEVE IN
FREEDOM.
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF OUR
COUNTRY.
AMERICA IS MORE THAN A COUNTRY,
WE ARE AN IDEA, AN IDEA OF
SELF-GOVERNANCE.
REMEMBER, THIS WAS THE 30-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF TIANANMEN SQUARE.
WATCH THE TANKS ROLLED INTO THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO DID UP
AND BUILD LIKE THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY, JUST THE IDEA OF
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CHINA TODAY,
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN CHINA
GETS A SOCIAL SCORE.
THEY ARE DENIED WHETHER THEY CAN
FILE A PLANE IF THEY DON'T SPEAK
THE WAY THE GOVERNMENT WANTS
THEM TO.
INSIDE HONG KONG WITH THOSE WHO
ARE STANDING FOR FREEDOM, I WANT
THEM TO KNOW THAT AMERICA STANDS
WITH YOU.
THE SAME THAT WE STAND WITH THE
SHIPYARD WORKERS IN POLAND IN
THE FOSTER 80s, THE SAME
REASON THAT WE STAND WITH THOSE
IN VENEZUELA THAT CLAIM FREEDOM
AS WELL.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT IS
APPEARING TO BACK OFF PLANS TO
COMMUTE THE SENTENCE OF FORMER
ILLINOIS
GOVERNOR ROD BLAGOJEVICH.
IS THAT A PUSH FROM HOUSE
REPUBLICANS?
>> I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHERE
AND ANOTHER PRESIDENT NEVER SAID
HE WAS, HE WAS ACTUALLY
ANALYZING IT.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD RELEASE THE FORMER
GOVERNOR.
I THINK IT'S 4 OUT OF 5 OF THE
LAST GOVERNORS OF ILLINOIS HAVE
BEEN IN JAIL AND HAVE BEEN IN
JAIL BECAUSE THEY STOOD BEFORE
AND HAD A JURY OF THEIR PEERS
MAKE A DECISION.
I THINK THEY SHOULD SERVE THEIR
TIME AND I THINK THAT'S CORRECT
THAT THE PRESIDENT MAKES THAT
DECISION TO MAKE THEM CONTINUE
TO SURFACE TIME.
>> Bret: THE SOUTHERN BORDER
ISSUE, DEMOCRATS EXPRESSING
CONCERN ABOUT EMINENT DOMAIN
SAYING WE ARE TROUBLED BY THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY,
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED GIVEN
LANDOWNERS WHOSE PROPERTY WAS
SEIZED DURING PROVERB THOUGH MY
PRIOR BORDER BARRIER
CONSTRUCTION EFFORTS TOLD
CONGRESS THEY DID NOT RECEIVE
JUST COMPENSATION FOR THEIR
LAND, THEY WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING THIS TIME WITH
EFFORTS TO BUILD A WALL.
>> THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
HAVING OPEN BORDERS.
I'VE NEVER UNDERSTOOD THE
SITUATION WHERE YOU CAN SEE A
CRISIS.
ANY HEARINGS IN JUDICIARY ABOUT
THIS?
IS OF ANY ACTION?
NOW THAT DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT EMINENT DOMAIN OR PRIVATE
PROPERTY, I THINK THAT'S FAR,
FAR FROM IT BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
SEEN THEM CARE ABOUT THAT
BEFORE.
ALL THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
HAVING AN OPEN BORDERS SYSTEM
WHICH IS NOT -- WE WANT TO HAVE
LEGAL IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND WE
WANT ONE THAT ACTUALLY WORKS.
>> Bret: YOUR COLIC
REPRESENTATIVE STEVE KING WAS
TALKING TO A CONSERVATIVE CLUB
WEDNESDAY AND HE SAID THAT
HUMANITY MIGHT NOT EXIST AT ALL
IF NOT FOR RAPE AND THROUGHOUT
HUMAN HISTORY.
IF YOU PULLED OUT A PRODUCT FOR
RAPE WOULD THERE BE ANY
POPULATION WITH CONNECTIVITY
PROBLEMS WITH THAT?
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
HAD CONCERNS WITH WHAT
STEVE KING SAID.
EARLIER IN THIS CONGRESS, OTHER
THINGS -- I DO NOT BELIEVE THE
PARTY OF LINCOLN WITH STANFORD.
AS THE UNITED CONGRESS DONE MY
CONFERENCE WE ACTUALLY MOVED
REMOVED STEVE KING FROM HIS